to be part of our plans going forward
but that will be a decision that i won't
make
you know matt uh is is
has the ability to play at a very high
level even at this age whether that's
going to continue or not i'm not sure
i appreciate his
willingness to consider doing that and
uh and the level of what he's played for
for us for 13 years which has been
incredible
uh so i i will have to say but then
again that's going to be a decision at
the end of the day that'll be part of it
be up to the player and possibly be up
to the coaching staff and whether or not
you know matt can keep himself together
and god willing to be able to do that
and
play at the level that he's capable of
playing
arthur blank owned the falcons yesterday
speaking to a pool reporter who was
funneling questions from other reporters
kind of strange not really a press
conference but addressing the question
of matt ryan's
prior expression of a desire to play
until he's 40. he's 35 and that was
hardly a hell yes matt ryan is our
quarterback from arthur blank that was
the next guys are going to figure that
out chris and it just makes me wonder
what the next guys are going to want and
also whether matt ryan is going to want
to stay yeah i think that's they're both
legitimate questions i mean matt ryan he
might not he might look and go okay wait
this next staff's going to come in here
and like you know
rip the band-aid off and we're going to
start back in scratch he might say the
hell with that it's been a great run see
you later the next coaching staff might
come in and just go you know we want to
start from scratch and we don't really
want matt ryan we'd like to have a young
guy and just do it our own way trevor
you know we're the the falcons
they could be in play here for the
number one pick we don't know i mean if
trevor lawrence is on the board and matt
ryan's 36 and you're the number one pick
in the draft i think you probably make
that move as great as i think matt ryan
is
i don't think there's a lot of thought
there it's shaping up right now to be
the most
unbelievable um
what do i want to say just fight for the
number one pick for one guy that i've
ever seen it really is it is i mean the
jets and giants are talking about it up
here i mean the way it's shaping right
now we're going to have more people in a
fight over trevor lawrence than i can
ever remember one quarterback being you
know so much uh whatever love or wanted
or whatever i'm trying to say there
the thing about matt ryan he's got 44
million in dead money left under his
contract as of next year which makes it
very hard to cut him or trade him not
that they would cut him he's got a 40
million dollar cap number for next year
so
you may
you may have to move on from him and and
save 23 million in cash take a bigger
cap hit
but you've you've you've cleared off
this 40 that you already were going to
take because maybe he doesn't want to
cooperate and do some sort of a
restructuring and reduce that number
here's the other thing too there is a
chance that the new regime may want to
keep him for a year just because it kind
of gives the new regime a scholarship
year right you know we we've seen
coaching staff do that where this year
doesn't really count and we we had our
hands tied we couldn't cut him we
couldn't trade him so we just have to
see what we can do we'll evaluate him
this year yeah make a decision after
this year so if next year goes to hell
that doesn't count against the new
regime exactly right they get the reset
in 2022. yeah that that is a very old
play by coaches let's see how it goes if
it goes bad you know this is not really
the guy i want in any ways it's not the
quarterback i wanted in here for my team
blah blah blah and they have that excuse
and then if it goes good it's oh hey
okay yeah well we thought matt ryan and
this quarterback could do well we'll see
falcons are in a tough spot with their
salary cap and they got a lot of things
to be answered for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports